by someone named Chancellor might work  on the communities for current holder of  a visit this morning to council to see  their refurbished website changing rooms  you see behind me there new doors with  the finger protector fits on the side  really impressed with the work done here  will change you to a lot better  please tidy and very colorful so I'm  Dennis on the internet you it's infusion  frame itself we almost come to the  indoor power we felt in the moment as  well with obviously lots of more items  to country to them as well the feedback  we've had for attending  they go out in it's been fantastic and  we're hoping so normally requests these  words it's a light snack confusion for  their hard work and their commitment to  counsel fantastic now very close a very  vast improvement I was gay before and  understands for staff and then work so  yeah based economy is my testing  facility in our community